So, Sam, you're going to teach me how to build this app.
I guess that means we're going to do a lot of coding?
>> None whatsoever. It's all going to be using point and click.
>> And what does that mean, point and click? What will we actually be doing?
>> There'll be a little bit of pointing. You know, clicking with the mouse.
>> Okay, thanks.
[LAUGH]
>> And at the end you're going to have a
really fully functional web and mobile app. It's really cool.
>> All right. Sounds good.
>> No, but seriously. In the first lesson,
you're going to create an app and learn how Salesforce
stores data. In lesson two, you'll learn how
to take a big problem and break it into
smaller pieces, and how to represent those pieces
in Salesforce. In lesson three, you're going to learn how
to visualize your data with fancy charts and graphs,
and pi charts. In lesson four, you learn how
to automate the things you've been doing by hand using
workflows and approvals. Finally, in lesson five, you're going to take that
web app you've been developing and turn it into a
mobile app that you can take with you anywhere you go.